et quelqu'un ici je vous ai fait pas
d'accord pas du tout mon ami est allé se
gaver allez vous asseoir et c'est
vraiment votre avis tous les hommes qui
paie sont mes amis trop peu se revoir
c'est juste parce que tout est là
parfois je me dis que tu serais capable
de tuer quelqu'un c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui
non c'est pas tout jeter fils et 20000
euros d'avancé je vois toujours rien
venir tu m'avais promis une nouvelle
pièce clé en main après maintenant j'ai
dû rêver le seul en scène autrement
c'est l'histoire d'une prostituée dans
une vie d'épreuves
elle rencontra je vois un type qui
devient fou d'être ta musique une bonne
saison
vous avez tort de vous mettiez soyez
beaucoup plus belles sens par voyage le
type david se rende compte qu'elle est
froide calculatrice monteuse égoïste et
il décide de la battre à son propre jeu
un tgv salle pour les retraites à nantes
hier je ne supporte pas qu'on me prenne
pour une conne
le team va tout faire pour qu'elle tombe
amoureuse de l'auto et va c'est vrai
prénom qu'est ce que vous appelez ça
comment je m'appelle intrigue ce genre
de bonne femme est incapable d'être
amoureux justement tu le public va dire
la même chose
est-ce qu'il va réussir à le piéger ou
non je suis venu pour tuer et fera
toujours rire
rue du riez
[Musique]